hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
section 10 of David hume's inquiry
concerning human understanding is titled
on Miracles and it's divided into two
main parts he's setting out a problem
and the question isn't simply do
Miracles exist or not but do we have
good grounds for thinking in any given
case that a miracle has actually taken
place and this is connected with this
conception of testimony we learn a lot
of things not through our own direct
experience but by being reported to us
offered to us you could say in various
kinds of literature or nowadays it could
be you know through videos or other
things like that and he begins by
talking about this Dr Tillotson arguing
against the real presence we're not
going to worry so much about that but he
says that you know a decisive argument
of this kind which must at least silence
bigotry and Superstition you know is
something good and he says I flatter
myself I have discovered an argument of
a like nature which if just will with
the wise and learn it be an everlasting
check to all kinds of superstitious
delusion and consequently will be useful
as long as the world endures for so long
I presume well the accounts of Miracles
and prodigies be found in history sacred
and profane so that that's his goal
right he's constructing an argument and
before we get to the point where Hume is
actually going to ultimately provide us
with reasons for rejecting testimony
bearing upon what appear to be miracles
we have to do a little bit of stage
setting and that's what he's doing in
the first section here primarily so you
can look at this as expository rather
than simply argumentative and he begins
by talking about experience which he's
been running through in the entire work
experience can be our only guide in in
reasoning concerning matters of fact and
he says that this guide is not
altogether infallible but in some cases
can lead us into errors and he provides
as an example one who in our climate
that of Scotland should expect better
weather in any week of June than in one
of December would reason justly and
conformably to experience but it is
certain that he may happen in the event
to find himself mistaken we can have
freak occurrences where you know it's
warmer in December than it is in June or
pick whatever else you want sometimes
things go wrong and he says we can
observe in such a case he would have no
cause to to complain of experience
because it commonly informs us of the
uncertainty by that contrarity of events
which we may learn by a diligent
diligent observation what is a
contrarity things not turning out as we
would expect them they can contradict
each other right so he says all effects
follow not with like certainty from
their supposed causes some events are
found in all countries in all ages
constantly conjoined together others are
found to have been more variable
sometimes to disappointing our
expectations and he says you know we're
stuck most of the time with probability
something that he discussed earlier in
section six right
so you know what we ought to do because
experience is variable he says we should
proportion our belief to the evidence
this is what he says a wise person does
and so he says in conclusions that are
founded on an infallible experience now
it's hard to see where there could be an
infallible experience given Humes other
things that he said about experience but
let's just go with him on that so if
there is an infallible experience we
expect the event with the last degree of
assurance and we regard past experience
as a full proof of the future existence
of that event okay so if we've never
been disappointed by experience we can
say okay it's going to turn out this way
in the future
but if it's merely probable if things
sometimes aren't quite so constant he
says well then he weighs the opposite
experiments he considers which side is
supported by the greater number of
experiments and now he doesn't mean a
scientific experiment with a very rigid
methodology he just means experiences
right and so he says he inclines to the
side which is supported by the greater
number so that side inclines with doubt
and hesitation and when he fixes his
judgment the evidence succeeds not what
we call probability so we can say well
I'm 90 certain or I'm pretty certain
that this will be the case that's
proportioning belief to evidence so
he says we can consider a particular
instance what is the particular instance
well it's actually something quite
General so particular might be a little
misleading here he says that we may
observe there's no species of reasoning
more common more useful and even
necessary to human life than that which
is derived from the testimony of men and
the reports of eyewitnesses and
Spectators now let's pause there for a
moment how do we know probably 99 of the
things that we believe that we say we
actually do know well it is in large
respect based on testimony people saying
this is the case or like it says reports
by eyewitnesses and Spectators or it's
reports about what other people have
reported and we can go on and on and on
with this and he says this species of
reasoning one may deny to be founded on
the relay nation of cause and effect but
I'm not going to dispute about that it
will be sufficient to observe our
assurance and any arguments of this kind
is derived from no other principle than
our observation of the veracity of human
testimony right so we have a lot of
experiences of people saying yes this is
the case and then we go and we check it
out and it turns out that actually is
the case and we're like yeah okay cool
and so we can rely on most people being
truthful with us most of the time in
most circumstances right and the
Conformity as he says a usual Conformity
of facts to the reports of witnesses and
so he says it being a general Maxim no
objects have any discoverable connection
together and all the inferences we can
draw on from one to another founded on
the experience of their constant and
regular conjunction we shouldn't make an
exception to this Maxim in favor of
human testimony whose connection with
any event seems as little necessary as
any other so why do we believe what
other people tell us because in large
part we have found them to be more or
less reliable
what do we do however when we're
confronted with what he calls a
contrarity of evidence where there are
different people saying different things
even contradictory things about the same
event or same sequence of events he says
well there's a lot of different factors
involved in this right so how do we
decide about this he says that there's a
number of different possibilities the
contrary of evidence may be derived from
different causes from the opposition or
contradiction of contrary testimony so
people say a lot of different things
about something and we're like well I
don't know quite who to believe right or
we might be attending to as he says the
character or number of witnesses right
or uh from their manner of delivering
their testimony or the union of all of
these circumstances in real life
situations there may in fact be a number
of these playing a role and he he sums
this up by saying we entertain a
suspicion concerning any matter of fact
when the witnesses contradict each other
when they have but few or of doubtful
character when they have an interest in
what they affirm when you know they're
saying things it would be nice for them
to be true when they deliver their
testimony with hesitation or on the
contrary with two violent ass servations
there being two
um we could say emphatic in how they're
telling us that so we should be kind of
on edge kind of suspicious when when
that's the case
so there's a lot of things he says where
you know maybe we don't buy them
and he goes on and he says
um suppose that the fact which the
testimony Endeavors to establish
partakes of the extraordinary the
marvelous in that case the evidence
resulting from the testimony admits of a
diminution greater or less in proportion
as the fact is more or less unusual so
you know for example spontaneous human
combustion is that a real thing or not
if people are very worried about that in
the 1970s I remember quite a few
relatives being concerned with that and
he says well the reason we place any
credit in Witnesses and historians is
not derived from any connection we
perceive a priori between testimony and
reality but because we're accustomed to
find a Conformity between them so when
something kind of crazy happens we're
like yeah I don't know if I'm gonna buy
that you know unless we're rather
credulous people or were you know we're
relying on somebody's character as you
know not
um being impeachable or impute notable
which usually turns out to be false and
Huma is going to go on and he talks
about the difference between the
marvelous something being only marvelous
and something being really miraculous
these are not the same thing for him
something that's marvelous I mean it
could be the case it could not be the
case it doesn't imply a violation of the
laws of nature because that is what
makes a miracle a miracle in hume's eyes
this is how he defines a miracle a
miracle is a violation of the laws of
nature he says a little bit later in a
footnote he's going to add to this he
says a miracle May accurately be defined
as a transgression of a law of nature by
a particular volition of the deity or
the interposition of some invisible
agent it's kind of you know adding to
that definition but the idea here is
that there's laws of nature that we
human beings can uncover and a miracle
contradicts them a miracle violates them
it's not just something interesting or
rare it's something that really
shouldn't be at all so he says
as a firm and unalterable experience has
established these laws the proof against
a miracle from the very nature of the
fact is his entire as any argument from
experience can possibly Be Imagined so
you know you could say that by
definition for Hume a miracle can't be
true you can't have a violation of the
laws of nature and he you know there's a
lot of examples of this one of the
examples that he gives is a dead person
coming back to life a really dead person
not just somebody who we think is dead
and we accidentally bury them or
something we're mistaken that's not a
violation of laws of nature that's
actually following the laws of nature
but a dead person a genuinely dead
person being resurrected or however
we're going to say it he says that is a
violation it's never been observed in
any age or country and here we might say
well wait a second people have said that
they've observed this sort of thing we
can think of all sorts of examples we
might think of the biblical example of
Jesus telling Lazarus to come out of the
Tomb uh doesn't that count and Hume
would say well we need to look into this
more carefully and he tells us that
a miracle is not actually going to
happen why he says there must be a
uniform experience against every
miraculous event otherwise the event
would not Merit that appellation so by
the very way in which we're
understanding miracle there's going to
be experiences against it and he says as
a uniform experience amounts to a proof
here is direct and full proof from the
nature of the fact against the existence
of any Miracle nor can any proof be
destroyed or the miracle render rendered
credible by an opposite proof which is
superior so this is where he's actually
heading in the next section where he's
going to give arguments and he does have
this interesting footnote that we should
discuss
in the footnote he points out that
sometimes an event may not in itself
seem to be contrary to the laws of
nature yet if it were real it might by
reason of some circumstances be
denominated that is called a miracle
because in fact as opposed to how it
seems it is contrary to those laws so he
says if a person claiming a Divine
Authority should command a sick person
to be well a helpful man to fall down
dead the clouds to pour rain the winds
to blow in short should order many
natural events which immediately follow
on his command these might justly be
esteemed Miracles why because they
really are contrary to the laws of
nature
they're a transgression of of that
somebody saying something shouldn't make
these effects happen right the last
thing that he's going to say here is
leading us into the next section where
he's going to directly attack miracle
goals based on testimony
he says the plain consequence is and he
says this is a general maximum worthy of
our attention
no testimony no testimony at all is
sufficient to establish a miracle
unless there is a particular condition
of that testimony and now notice the way
that he frames this this is very
important
no testimony is sufficient to establish
a miracle unless the testimony be of
such kind that it's falsehood would be
more miraculous than the fact it
Endeavors to establish right so when
somebody tells me he saw a dead man
restored to life I consider with myself
whether it be more probable the
alternate theory that this person should
either deceive or be deceived or the
fact which he relates should have really
happened I weigh as he says one Miracle
against another so when somebody is
providing testimony about a miracle I
have to say well what is actually more
likely that this person is deceived or
deceiving or maybe there was some sort
of weird you know natural law explicable
event or that an actual Miracle took
place and unless it's more likely that a
miracle took place we're not going to
accept that sort of testimony this human
says can be a general Maxim so something
that we rely upon
as a rule of thumb you could say and so
this is about as far as he gets in
section one he is set up his
understanding of Miracles and its
relation to probability and to testimony